il est déjà pas bien euh pierre en ce
moment je n'oublie pas les victimes et
évidemment bien sûr petit bébé de enfin
40 oui il avait 40 minutes en fait
tous ceux qui souffrent en ce moment à
l'hôpital évidemment qu'on oublie pas ça
c'est un défendable donc je défends pas
ça du tout j'ai que j'aime pas la Laly
j'aime pas la curé j'aime pas le
lynchage tu connais la règle des trois
ailes dans le métier tu lèches tu lâches
et tu lâches et aujourd'hui on est en
plein lâchage médiatique alors moi je
trouve que tu connais le dossier moi je
le connais pas ce que vous connaissez le
dossier entièrement je ne le connais pas
est-ce que Myriam ne le connais
peut-être plus que moi mais je suis
certain qu'on nous dit pas tout bon
alors donc c'est pas à nous à juger moi
je suis pas juge il y a des magistrats
pour ça que tu as même dit que tu avais
limite envie de Lily quoi de le sortir
de là
j'ai pas compris tu as même dit que tu
avais limite envie de l'aider de le
sortir de là tellement il est mal
tellement on le linge que bon c'est vrai
qu'au bout d'un moment bon ça suffit ça
va si on pouvait peut-être moins en
parler ça serait peut-être un petit peu
mieux bon voilà donc est-ce que est-ce
que ce que je dis c'est exorbitant c'est
pas bien ou c'est bien moi ça me choque
explique pourquoi ça me choque parce que
quand vous dites il est mort je suis
désolé mais il y a un côté quel dommage
que les médias parlent de l'affaire quel
dommage que Pierre Palmade ne soit pas
soutenu il a pris une voiture en ayant
consommé
il est mort non il est pas mort son
avocate fait des démarches etc il aura
le droit à un procès
de regretter qu'il soit mort
immédiatement je suis désolé
est-ce que tu veux l'enfoncer encore
plus c'est ça que tu veux moi je dis non
c'est tout moi j'ai pas envie de voir ça
il est déjà il est complètement tu
Guillaume je comprends pas il y a une
leçon d'amis à quoi servent les amis si
dans les ces moments ils sont terribles
il y a pas au moins tu as toute la
France contre 4 5 amis qui sont te dire
tu as rien fait de mal mais ils sont
moins là pour t'aider peut-être à te
relever une fois que je suis tout à fait
d'accord mais je veux dire ton
fonctionnement
ce qu'il a fait ils l'ont dit voilà en
premier bien sûr aux victimes mais à
cette famille bien sûr mais il a pas
voulu il est passé c'est une conséquence
de son état et de sa maladie et que les
premières voilà donc
Pierre Palmade les journalistes ont
droit d'en parler ça soulève quand même
des problèmes de société qui dépassent
la faire pire pas mal qui sont
importants pour la société et moi par
contre je trouve pas qu'on en fasse trop
on est très factuel il y a un débat en
plus judiciaire sur le traitement de
l'affaire tout le monde n'est pas l'ami
de Pierre Palmade moi que ses amis ils
défendent ça me choque pas en revanche
qu'on en parle à la télé c'est normal
pardon bien sûr bah oui Béatrice de
s'acharner sur Pierre Palmade l'homme
c'est que la société se saisit d'un
sujet il a besoin d'être sur la place
publique qui a besoin d'être mise en
lumière pour que ce soit débattu pour
que peut-être il y a une jurisprudence
sur les gens qui consomment de l'alcool
ou de la drogue et prennent leur voiture
ça n'est pas fait contre Pierre Palma il
y a pas un complot contre lui pour être
méchant avec lui c'est juste un sujet
grave qui a mené à la mort d'un bébé à
la décimé une famille et voilà et parce
que c'est une célébrité que ce soit
Pierre Palmade Madonna ou peu importe on
en parle parce que c'est une célébrité
mais ça concerne toute la société et
c'est bien parce que ça va nous faire
avancer en tant que société alors je
peux comprendre ce que ce que vous dites
très bien mais moi je pense pas la même
chose je dis que ça on en parle trop
c'est tout ça fait combien de temps
qu'on est dessus depuis le premier jour
Cyril depuis le premier jour bon parce
que ça fait beaucoup d'audience
j'imagine depuis le 10 février bon
oui juste tu dis c'est factuel je suis
pas d'accord avec toi ce qu'il a fait
encore une fois c'est atroce quand on
parle de sa sexualité de ce qui fait ses
nuits de quelle équipe on va
quand on décrit ce qui fait dans sa vie
sexuelle à lui qui se tape un mec de
micro excuse-moi c'est son problème donc
on est effectivement je suis assez
d'accord il y a aussi une feuille de
voilà ça aussi un petit peu débordé de
voilà l'homosexualité de voilà mais oui
bien sûr mais arrête bien sûr que oui je
dis pas encore une fois on n'est pas là
pour le défendre mais je te dis ce que
dit Julien il faut aussi l'entendre tu
le comprends il y a il y a il y a les
côtés factuels et sans la tous dit on
pourra pas faire machine arrière c'est
terminé mais maintenant aujourd'hui
effectivement peut-être on peut lui
lâcher les basses et encore une fois il
y a un jus qui va condamné et ça et ça
ne répare rien évidemment ni ce qu'il a
fait et ça voilà
Delphine après Guillaume effectivement à
partir du moment où on a fait un exemple
ou justement un contre exemple
maintenant c'est bon on le sait et c'est
en ça que moi je vous comprends dans
cette société là c'est un peu quand il y
a des choses qui se passent mal on a
nouveau un peu le l'instinct animal
c'est-à-dire que quand on voit une
goutte de sang et ben il y a tout le
monde qui va aller dessus effectivement
cet homme là déjà à terre et ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que bien sûr c'est
un accident à la conséquence de son
mauvais comportement et de ses
addictions mais ça reste un accident
parce que volontairement s'il avait à
choisir il serait il serait pas
mal
d'accord tous les détails de sa vie
Guillaume tous les détails de sa vie qui
sortent servent le propos la drogue ça
sert le propos lequel sexe et le point
de départ d'accident pardon mais je
crois qu'on a on a un peu éclipsé la
pédoporno pornographie pour la guerre il
a été certes innocenté il y a rien
pardon
il y a quand même encore
dit qu'ils n'ont rien retrouvé sur les
disques durs de de Pierre Palmade à part
l'existence par par les policiers sur
cette histoire je voulais juste dire
qu'on a parlé de l'existence d'une vidéo
où il regarde une vidéo pas de
pornographique en disant ça va c'est OK
qui
faire des vidéos P2 pornographiques donc
voilà donc tous ces détails qui sont
révélés par la presse je suis désolé ils
servent la faire il pose des questions
de société et on ne s'acharne pas sur
pierre pas mal encore une fois vous
dites il est mort médiatiquement mais ça
va durer quoi six mois un an deux ans le
bébé il est mort tout court voilà
Alexandre qu'est-ce que tu penses toi
toute cette histoire toi qui a un regard
extérieur en plus je veux savoir bah moi
je suis peiné je suis déçu quand même je
rejoint Julien
c'est un homme il a fait une connerie
c'est grave maintenant il y a un procès
est terminé quoi après
il voulait pas c'est il a pas fait ça
lui il est il a il peut le choisir entre
faire cet accident on peut le faire il
aurait pas fait après je trouve qu'il y
a quand même une hypocrisie il y a quand
même une hypocrisie un petit peu globale
pas forcément médiatique mais bien pas
le même voilà on sait très bien que ça
fait longtemps qu'il est qu'il est pris
dans des pas dans le milieu tout ça tu
savais aussi toi aussi que c'était voilà
non mais c'est vrai
tu savais quoi là que voilà oui je
comprends que la justice médiatique vous
choque et qu'il y a une de voyeurisme
mais malgré tout vous trouvez pas qu'il
a été quand même le cobaye utile d'une
sorte de faits divers comme ça un peu
extraordinaire un peu exceptionnel avec
des vrais sujets de société la récidive
comment se fait-il qu'il a un permis de
conduire alors qu'on savait que c'était
quelqu'un qui était sous emprise et qui
consommait de la drogue moi ça me pose
des problèmes par exemple de
fonctionnement de la société vous
comprenez ce que je veux dire
j'ai trouvé que c'était très important
qu'on en parle qu'on fasse de la
prévention on écoutait par les jeunes
qu'on dise pourquoi c'est grave pourquoi
c'est dangereux pourquoi et les
phénomènes d'emprise tous ces sujets de
société certes ok ça tombe sur lui et
ben c'est devenu un cobaye médiatique et
oui évidemment qu'on le pire mais malgré
tout voilà c'est le revers de cette
médaille tragique en fait c'est double
peine et c'est triples Jean-Marie
en plus quand tu te contentes
tu viens pour dire faut plus en parler
en fait on en parle quoi
et que c'est vrai que il y a des
rebondissements tous les jours je pense
qu'il y a un truc très important c'est
qu'est-ce qui va se passer qu'est-ce qui
peut se passer pour Pierre Palmade qui a
été mon ami si consacre sa vie tout
entière à essayer de réparer ce qu'il a
fait c'est-à-dire s'il consacre son
énergie son son argent pour essayer si
Dieu veut que ces personnes récupèrent
de la validité il y a une encore un
petit trou de souris mais peu encore
peut-être s'en sortir si il est monté
s'il est d'une exemplarité formidable
c'est-à-dire de stopper net toute
consommation de quoi que ce soit et de
consacrer toute son énergie du matin
jusqu'au soir à essayer de de faire que
les dommages collatéraux soient les
moindres quoi bon il y a que comme ça
qui pourrait récupérer un petit peu de
moi je suis désolé mais je voulais
répondre à Jean-Michel et à Julien on
peut être ami de Pierre Palmade mais on
a un devoir de silence je suis désolé
je trouve choquant qu'on s'exprime
publiquement en tant qu'ami de Pierre
Palmas
pour moi non on ne peut pas parler
publique
la décence et le sirop absolu je parle
de Julien
c'est pas un ami
comme nous tous ici
ça n'a rien à voir
en tout cas pas le défendre et
Jean-Michel disait les amis
je suis désolé je n'ai pas entendu mais
je suis désolé il faut que tu vois le
Torino qui surveille tes oreilles
a été un des plus durs hein
excuse-moi de te réveiller je pense
évidemment on en fait beaucoup parce que
il y a quand même eu par exemple une
petite musique où on a on a dit qu'il va
peut-être se suicider qui va même
falloir vraiment le protéger s'il est en
prison il va falloir le protéger pour
qu'il ne se situe pas mais est-ce que on
a pensé une seule seconde ici dans cette
salle à la dame à qui on a rendu un
enfant des figuré Qui va avoir des c'est
ce qu'on a dit au début
[Musique]
on a pensé qu'elle pouvait suicider
est-ce que quelqu'un va la protéger je
ne crois pas
et on est dans les médias donc voilà je
trouve que quand même il est c'est
quelqu'un de connu et on y fait un peu
plus attention et quand l'accident je
pense pas que ce soit le terme parce que
quand on ne dort pas pendant trois nuits
qu'on se drogue qu'on prend deux fois sa
voiture dans la même journée pour aller
à la boulangerie
le mot accident c'est quelque chose que
tu ne tu ne choisis pas bah il a choisi
de se droguer
mais il aurait très bien pu ne pas faire
d'accident comme les gens tu bois un
coup de chaud mais non mais
que je tire sur cette dame et que je la
rate donc j'ai rien fait c'est pas grave
non parce que je l'ai raté
qui rentre de leur soirée en voiture et
ils espèrent qu'il se passera il se
passerait et si il se passe quelque
chose il ne voulait pas et bien sûr
Delphine pardon on peut parler
d'accident qui à moitié ce drame il
était quand même en partie prévisible et
moi ce qui me choque c'est pas le
traitement médiatique de maintenant
c'est le traitement médiatique d'avant
en fait
sur des plateaux encore une fois on a
revu une archive il y a quelques années
où il disait au calme voilà moi je me
défonce je fais des soirées je fais du
CAM sex ils sont cachés pas sur les
réseaux sociaux sur les sites de
rencontres il écrivait premier message
qu'il écrivait cam sex voilà donc ça
c'était normal c'était cool parce que
c'est une célébrité parce que c'est une
star pour dire rien
évidemment donc au contraire le
traitement médiatique de maintenant il
rectifie et il dit aux gens que la
drogue non c'est pas cool c'est pas
parce qu'on est une star qu'on a droit
de se défoncer et de se et de faire
n'importe quoi la drogue c'est de la
merde ça tue ceux qui en prennent et ça
tue ceux qui croisent le chemin de ceux
qui en prennent justement on va parler
des proches de Pierre Palma d'après
Jean-Michel Thionville avec Myriam miam
tu voulais déjà donner ton avis
là-dessus après tu vas nous donner
dernières infos
qu'on définit ce que c'est que lynchage
médiatique parce qu'en réalité on ne
fait que retranscrire les faits qui sont
déjà extrêmement difficiles et accablant
pour Pierre Palmade ce n'est pas du
lynchage ce n'est que on ne fait que
relater des faits qui sont terribles et
qui malheureusement sont à charge pour
lui non mais parler du feuilletonage
c'est-à-dire jour après jour
justement aujourd'hui il devait pas
passer alors
il n'est pas il devait plaider le
parquet a fait à référer des tensions
pour que ça levé de ça lever de liberté
pour enfin que la liberté provisoire
soit ne soit pas levée et il devait donc
se rendre à la cour d'appel de Paris
donc il n'y a pas été son avocate a
débattu avec avec le juge d'instruction
qui était là et pour l'instant il n'y a
pas de décision qu'il y a été prise elle
sera rendue publique mardi prochain pour
savoir si oui ou non il va rester sous
contrôle judiciaire en liberté soit à
l'hôpital soit chez lui ou si il va
aller à la prison de Fred